unfortunately these do-gooders have this
view that everybody's got goodness in
their heart sorry to disappoint you
everybody hasn't got goodness in their
heart you know and some people are
coming here because they want to make
money they don't want to pay tax and
they want to make use of whatever it is
that's here that they want that they
can't get it home
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantly kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant and returning guest
today as a journalist radio and tv
presenter mike graham welcome back to
trigonometry thank you very much i guess
you must have liked the last time we did
but you guys have gone up in the world a
bit thanks to you mike it was your
appearance joe rogan talks about you you
know what more can you want yeah we're
very pleased with how it's going and uh
you're doing very well as well we are
before we get into that uh just for
people who are new to the show who
didn't see our first interview tell
everybody a little bit about your
backstory who are you how are you where
you are what is your journey through
life yeah i mean i came to uh
broadcasting via newspapers um when they
used to be dangerous and and they used
to sell an awful lot of papers and we
used to drink an awful lot and uh you
know it was great fun so i sort of got
into journalism straight out of
university i didn't finish university i
just kind of decided to go go into it
never learned shorthand um never really
learned all the things you were supposed
to learn now never studied media they
didn't i don't think they had media
studies when i was around um did
economics and politics for a bit um and
got into fleet street just by of making
a phone call to the right person at the
right time got a shift
worked in america for 10 years came back
got fired a few times from various
different organs including the daily
express the daily mirror um worked for
piers morgan for a while he's now back
in the fold we're both working now for
the same company again and uh i sort of
ran out of road with newspapers because
um it was around about i guess the start
of the century which sounds like a long
time ago now
right after 9 11 sort of
2005-ish i suppose um and i just i was
offered a job in radio and i thought
okay i'll give that a go
and now i've gone from working in radio
initially with with a place in scotland
went through talk sport ended up in talk
radio and now we're at talk tv station
and you know the rest is history i
suppose and and here i am yeah you'll
have to keep interrupting me
well you used to you just do three-hour
shows
it's true i mean i do have this um i
suppose i was born to do this this job
you know because uh because i i find it
very difficult to stop talking as
opposed to starting we'll stop you but
before we get into some of the stuff
that's going on now you've obviously
like you say you've chronicled quite a
long time in journalism
how has the whole world of media changed
in your in your lifetime and in the time
that you've you know last night i was
watching there's a great documentary and
i don't normally give the bbc any credit
for anything but bbc four i've got this
great documentary series about margaret
thatcher and i watched the first one
last night and the amazing thing is
partly to see how
politics is covered back in those days
and they start with when she was in
opposition so it's before she won the
election 1979. and you know it's just a
lot more
old-fashioned looking you know the the
all the interviewers are men they're all
white
um the good old days yeah i mean you
know so there are some people that like
that
i mean now of course if you're a
middle-aged white man you got no chance
at the bbc you know but um
you know she was very much more direct i
think the world has become a much more
sophisticated place i think the voters
are more sophisticated the public are
more sophisticated they have the benefit
of of seeing guys like yourselves uh
they have the benefit of seeing all
sorts of other things in different media
but back then you know the bbc was kind
of it you know if you were not being
interviewed by somebody on panorama or
you weren't doing you know the news
there was really nowhere to go and i
think fleet street particularly was a
very much more important place i mean
they still got the ability i think to
influence the way people feel about
things but to a much smaller extent and
i think now we're in the age where
politicians can kind of present
themselves to the public
in such a different variety of ways that
they can kind of direct the narrative if
you like i mean boss johnson
you know has been i think an incredible
lesson
in just how to do whatever the hell you
want and keep getting away with it
because i think the actual
substance of journalism i think is has
disappeared to some extent you know it's
all about a 24-hour news cycle now
whereas it was never like that now you
know i said on monday when boris was
going through this vote of no confidence
he's going to get through it he's going
to turn i mean there were still people
pundits talking heads talking on all
sorts of different outlets saying he's
done he's finished he's toast he'll be
out by the end of the week somewhere
even saying he's going to lose the vote
none of that happened i think they're
getting it wrong more often now and they
get it right why do you think that is
mike i think it's because they're out of
touch
i don't think you know i can't be the
only person that talks to ordinary
people but we do talk to a lot of
ordinary people on on talk tv
and you know you get a sense of how
people feel in london it's a very
different world you know london has
become a little island of sort of
walkery to me um it's it's a labour
stronghold the only place label won an
election uh result in in the general
election in 2019 was putney and you
think really um you know sadiq khan won
another another term
labour will probably win the next one
and i just think that the journalists
are all now from more and more from
private education they're from oxbridge
particularly the broadcast one
and they're all sort of cut from the
same class i don't think they would know
a working class person they fell on one
you know maybe they've got a cleaner
who's probably from romania or something
you know but they don't i don't think
they understand the british public at
all
no
and that disconnect seems to be
happening more and more particularly
when you look at places like the bbc
yeah well you just think how do you
represent ordinary people in any shape
or form no and they talk about diversity
but actually they haven't got any
diversity you know because all the black
and brown people in the bbc are all
middle class they've all been to the
same colleges the same schools you know
rita chakrabarty is it doesn't matter
what color she is she's the same person
as hugh edwards is you know even though
they come from different places they
have the same outlook and now they're
talking about actually finding a space
for underprivileged white male kids you
know maybe they're going to bring some
in i don't make the toast maybe
but they have such a disdain i think for
ordinary people because they think if
you are in any way right wing you're
just a racist or you're just stupid if
you wanted brexit you must be an idiot
you know they've got this incredibly
sort of entitled view that that and i
don't know where this came from but only
they have got the right answer i was
listening this morning to the today
program which i've started doing
recently because
they hit the kind of interviews at a
certain time about 20 past
eight in the morning and they had
michael govan and this guy i don't even
know who it was it wasn't um robinson it
was whoever his mate was
really badgering michael gove as if you
know he was some kind of war criminal
you kind of go in sorry what's wrong
with you if you want to ask questions to
be challenging that's one thing but to
continually kind of badger the guy
it's not good radio it's not good
listening it's like it's where does that
come from because
in terms of what we do that is actually
one of the things we're doing the
opposite of and i think part of our
success is that we try to talk to people
with different opinions and we you know
we politely challenge them where we
disagree but generally we want to get
out of you what you think yeah we might
disagree with what you think but we want
to just get it down crystal clear what
do you actually do exactly and the best
way to do that is to let the person say
it so when does where does this idea
come from that someone has to be like
interrupted every three seconds and
challenged all the time i think it comes
from their own sort of psyche where they
have meetings where they maybe give each
other gold stars for you know putting
pinning michael gove out and making him
look stupid or making him you know feel
nervous or sweaty or something but yeah
it's true it's what they do they they
were kind of saying things to him about
um the cleaners for example i mean you
know at one point i found this hilarious
at one point during uh the sue grey
report um aftermath in the commons you
know kyocerma accused boris johnson of
making the cleaners clean up and you go
that's actually it's actually what they
do
they had to come in and clean and you go
well yeah there was vomit okay there was
wine well you know people are employed
as cleaners i don't wish to be
disparaging about cleaners but if you're
a cleaner you clean and that's your job
so i'm sorry if you don't like what
you're cleaning but you know that's kind
of what you do and they were saying to
go you know how does it feel to be part
of the ruling class that was horrible to
cleaners
and i thought to myself you know if i
was go if i would have said have you got
a cleaner i bet you have i mean somebody
cleans your house don't they have you
ever been rude to anybody are you
telling me nobody and they were
literally admonishing him for having a
culture of rudeness
inside of number 10 and it's like
one that's not a news story two it's
none of your business and three just can
actually piss off i mean that's what i
would have said and it's not that's why
you're not a politician like i suppose
so
well in the old days prescott used to
thump them didn't they they did yeah
well i mean lots of them did bernard
england moving snatches press secretary
thumps a bbc guy once for asking the
wrong question and punched him in the
stomach you know it was great nobody got
hurt yeah
i think somebody might have got home but
not much though
listen if you're a journalist you
haven't been punched by someone you're
not doing your job
there we go
but mike it's not just the bbc to give
them their due it's also channel four
they're even more to the left of the bbc
channel four which unusually for me has
somehow ended up in the reverse
situation with the football because i
was watching the football the other
night and channel four we're covering it
right this ridiculous i don't even know
what it's called
league of nations football or something
uh and before the hungarian game which
was equally hilarious for different
reasons
um
they had
some bloke i'd never seen in my life
before on the pitch with some woman
who apparently is a
female footballer called knobs i think
her name is somebody knobs jordan knobs
and i'm going how did channel 4 end up
with this the bbc have got women's
football channel 4 i've got real
football and you're kind of going
how did this happen channel 4 is
supposed to be the people that represent
the underrepresented yeah instead of
which we've now got mainstream gary
lineker and people saying isn't it great
um you know here's the new chelsea
manager and you're going sorry who no
it's the women's chelsea man you're not
allowed to say it's women's football you
just have to say it's football because
you have to pretend that it's as good
but everybody knows it's not
and it's like you know surely channel 4
should have the women's football and the
bbc should have the other stuff
shouldn't they i don't know yeah it it
does feel like that but let's but if you
look at their news reporting
it's so disgraceful oh it really is yeah
i mean jon snow was a joke i mean he
literally i used to watch channel 4 news
just to get annoyed you know
because not only was he not very good
but it was so biased and so ridiculous
um and i mean i don't even know what's
happening with channel 4 everyone's
worried it's going to be sold off and
taken over by some horrible evil you
know elon musk type figure um
good hopefully that will happen but now
it seems to be happening in all
directions so for example gb news and
talk tv arguably would be you know a
right wing a right off center yeah and
again sort of just kind of doing what
they do right and we seem to now end it
up in this position because i think the
mainstream media slid in a sort of
leftward direction for so long well now
we've created a world where there is no
balance it's just right and left right
and i think that's actually healthier
because in the end i mean noam chomsky
once said there's no such thing as not
being biased because wherever you come
from you have the training or the kind
of upbringing or you know you bring with
you wherever it was you came from you
cannot be unbiased so you might as well
not pretend that you are i think i mean
i would say to people when they go
you're supposed to be unbiased i'm like
who told you that i'm not supposed to be
unbiased i am who i am if you don't like
what i'm saying ring me up and argue
with me if i want to get somebody on who
disagrees with me then that's what i'll
do but there's no point in me pretending
that i see everything the same way i
mean not to pick on rita chakravarti
again she said at the end of one of the
jubilee sort of segments that they did
on thursday or friday of jubilee weekend
she said we realize this is not
everybody's cup of tea
and it's like what would you say that
for would you have said that if you were
covering the glastonbury festival
because that's not my cup of tea i don't
want to see 400 bbc uh people sent to
glastonbury over jolly and take a load
of ecstasy and pretend it's public
service broadcasting because it isn't
you know it's like ridiculous totally
mad so they they kid themselves that
they're balanced i think they actually
genuinely believe that they are
but they're not at all they're middle
class most of them sort of champagne
socialists um and they think all tories
are evil
you know i don't know where they get
that from yeah and it just and and the
thing is it's like it's like you said
they don't seem to realize no and then
you watch the content that they produce
and the way they question people and you
go this is so openly nakedly biased and
i don't even consider myself right of
center i don't but i'm watching this and
going you're patronizing me yeah you're
telling me what to think why not treat
me like an adult
interview the person and then i'll make
up my own mind right i mean only the bbc
would have conversations with their
audience you know is it wrong to fly the
flag you know well no it's not wrong to
fly the flag that's the end of the
debate isn't it
so you'd be okay with the ukrainian flag
though but you can't fly a union jack
because obviously that would make you a
racist it's a very perverse way to
approach the world you know especially
from the national broadcasting yeah
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthem has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
particularly as an immigrant to this
country i find it very odd how
in my lifetime particularly in my
lifetime i know this has always been a
british problem like i think it was all
well that they talked about this as well
how the the intelligence in britain
would would happily talk down their own
country but it's sort of in particular
in my lifetime since i came to this
country in 95 suddenly like being proud
of your country in any way has become
this deeply shameful thing and the
intelligentsia of course used to be
quite a small part of britain it was
kind of you know you'd run into these
people very rarely they didn't really
have much importance they were kind of
slightly curious oddities who would sort
of pop up on you know question time once
in a while but but peter hitchens makes
this point a lot that under tony blair
all of our institutions became kind of
honeycombed with these so-called
intellectuals and these kind of you know
left-wing ideologues who were generally
speaking privileged people mostly white
people who had somehow got to the top in
their university level they somehow got
put in charge of quangos and they
somehow got put in charge of political
organizations and now we've got a
massive problem because they're running
everything from the metropolitan police
to the nu to the nhs to you know the
border force civil service
all of the people that run these things
are intrinsically left-wing intellectual
ideologues and they think that for
example we shouldn't have borders we
should just invite anybody in that can
come you know we should teach that
four-year-old children live in scotland
can can become you know transgender if
they wish at the age of four i mean it's
madness it's totally mad and you see it
everywhere you see the police now where
every one of their cars especially the
metropolitan police they've all got
rainbows on yeah and
and rainbows are on the on the level
crossings and you're going
no
this should be a political right it
should be a political why is it that
they're embracing an ideology yeah and
it just turns people off i mean i put a
tweet out the other day about um i think
it was i can't remember who it was
nottinghamshire police or somebody uh
who put out this sort of lgbtqia
plus whatever i don't know it's becoming
like just put the alphabet in different
order and see where it goes um
and they put at the end of the tweet um
you know we will be watching the
response to this um in case of any hate
crime
and i went
so so what you're now like actually you
know
kind of asking for people to say things
which you can then prosecute them for
and i just commented you know what if
we're just laughing at you is that a
hate crime
probably and of course i got a load of
crap from a lot of you know
gay activists and all that but you know
you're not even allowed to laugh at them
you know they haven't come for me yet i
mean they might come bursting through
the door you know as we sit here but you
do worry that there are some people in
the police who would quite like to come
bursting through the door because of
something you thought or something you
said or something you laughed at
and you kind of go i mean i got things
like from people saying why would you
laugh at people because of their
sexuality
and i'm like well that's not what i was
doing i was laughing at the fact that
police think it's important to put out a
tweet that shows them all holding up a
rainbow flag it's not what they do i'd
like them to put up pictures of them
beating somebody you know with a with a
rubber truncheon who had committed a
crime that's what i'd like to see or you
know chasing that guy off the bridge who
they tasered who was apparently
threatening people and he's now
unfortunately dead but i mean that's
what the police should be doing you know
they shouldn't be holding up a rainbow
flag and going would you like you know
would you like me to come and talk to
you no i'd like to arrest some bad guys
you know i'd like to stop people
burglaring you know burgling my house
i know isn't it ridiculous i'd like you
to stop women from being attacked in the
street at midnight when you don't seem
to have any cars driving around making
sure it doesn't happen you know it'd be
really good if you had nobody in your
own [ __ ] police force who actually
started you know killing people that
would be good
that'd be good to focus on the one thing
that i find really funny about all of
this as well is like
uh you mentioned football football is
now this vehicle for the delivery of
social justice yeah ideology yeah which
is about how a world cup in [ __ ]
qatar in qatar
right where the fifa organization
actually put out again on you know pride
week or whatever it was a tweet saying
you know we're looking forward to qatar
2022 it will be a festival of diversity
and equality i'm like are you sure about
that i'm not sure that you know whether
they're going to start throwing some gay
people off buildings you know is that
part of the you know celebration for the
final yeah just kind of go sorry and
then gareth southgate the other day
comes out and says that you know it's
going to be very complicated when
there's a penalty shooter because he has
to consider whether or not to ask marcus
rashford and some of the other players
who happen to be black whether they
should take a penalty because they got a
load of abuse and it's like well
maybe if you taught them how to take
penalties they wouldn't get any abuse
and i'm sorry that they got abused but
the point is is that you know people who
play football get abused all the time
look at beckham remember
i mean they were hanging you know they
were saying we're going to murder
effigies yeah they were hanging effigies
from lamp posts unfortunately football
fans are not very nice you know as much
as we'd like them all to be nice
unfortunately you know manchester united
fans sing songs about liverpool fans
liverpool fans do the whole you know air
crash thing from munich you know it's
not very nice but it goes on you can't
police that you know it's like walking
into a room and going i wish everybody
would just be really nice
but that but that is the point we want
to police everything now and look nobody
is condoning idiots on the internet
saying horrible racist thing obviously
that shouldn't happen and it's
disgraceful but this idea that we have
to police every single little thing
online it
it's become an obsession
you know you hear about people online
making horrendous offensive jokes i
don't know if you followed the case of
that bloke who built a model of the
grenfell tower then set fire to it yeah
and he's obviously he's obviously a
[ __ ] let's be honest he's a [ __ ]
right who's not particularly bright but
when did it become illegal to become a
[ __ ] yeah but why are you going to
put the guy in jail exactly having
ruined his life ruined as a result we've
got one um i haven't actually seen or
what the the absolute details but
there's some tick tock story going
around about a guy who uh has been
suspended for his job he works for
tick-tock in london because he made a
speech at which he said he didn't think
it was a very good idea to give people
maternity leave
and you go okay well that's a view you
know it's not not the world's most
modern view but you know it's a view but
no he's been suspended from his job
because people were outraged by it and
it's like why are you outraged by that
you know there is actually a law that
gives people maternity leave people are
protected by that and so there's already
a situation in place where if you like
you say if the guy's a [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] you know just leave him to it
doesn't mean he's a criminal so mike one
of the things that we i can't remember
which guest deviser was but we've talked
about quite a bit is this idea that as
as we increasingly see government as a
solution and answer to all problems more
and more of this stuff starts to happen
because if anything is wrong in our
lives or our experience of interacting
with other people or
or anything that is wrong in our lives
it's the job of government to fix it so
if someone's saying something we don't
like
well it's the job of government you have
to fix it somebody should come from over
there and tell them to stop you know
yeah yeah i mean i think covered was to
blame for a lot of that i think people
got used to the fact that you know they
couldn't do anything
because the government said they
couldn't i mean i think sensible people
were slightly less rigid about that i
mean i think it reached kind of peak
madness when beth rigby uh one point
from sky asked the prime minister in one
of those god awful um you know
news briefings you know well you say we
can sunbathe on monday but can we
sunbathe on sunday are you kind of going
actually beth i'd rather you didn't take
your clothes off at all
but if you if you want to i'm pretty
sure you'll be okay somebody on sunday
and not waiting until monday are you
kind of going why are you asking
permission for that what's wrong with
you why do you need to be given an
instruction
as to whether or not you can do
something just do it
you know and i think we've i think there
are a lot of people in this country who
quite like being told what to do
unfortunately i'm not one of them
and
that is hitting the nail on the head and
what i've been surprised at
a conservative government have come in
yeah since twenty nine say that yeah i
mean and i don't think there's anything
concerned about them is there no
no they they they've been
encroaching into everybody's lives
particularly during the pandemic right
they've put in laws about protesting
which i find incredibly worrying
trafficking money up the wall staffing
money up the wall and then we've got
this cost of living crisis which is
obviously awful terrible and their
solution is just to throw money at the
problem and we've got spiking inflation
i mean here's some money to pay your um
to pay you your electricity bill i mean
that's ridiculous right they're
supposedly taking the money back from
the windfall tax but in the end don't
pay people money and keep the price high
so that these people can continue to
make money as profiteers and then we're
all paying for it it's completely mad
and the one thing they come up with
today to give people on housing benefit
the ability to buy their own home you
know whereby in one fell swoop you you
stop uh the ability of people to get
into a house because they can't afford
to buy one because you've reduced the
stock and two you're then giving them
the ability to buy a house with money
given to them by people who can't afford
to buy a house
you're kind of going sorry what is the
point of any of this you know instead of
building some houses instead of building
somehow they claim they're building
houses but they're clearly not building
houses and if they are building houses
they build them sort of willy-nilly
without any thought to the pressure on
schools the pressure on hospitals on
doctors you know we've got a lot of
people in this country now more than we
had and nobody wants to talk about it
nobody wants to say we've got 10 million
more people here than we should have had
we've got you know a million people here
probably over the course of the last 10
years who've come here illegally who are
now living here nobody wants to talk
about that because that's racist
apparently but since we've come on to to
the government uh what have you made of
uh you you mentioned earlier that boris
johnson being able to literally get away
with what to me
are like the cardinal sin of politics
which is you're saying everyone must do
something and you're not doing it
how's that happening yeah i mean i think
it's partly because he's just very
stubborn and nobody really knows how to
deal with somebody who doesn't follow
the rules because we've now constructed
this kind of you know um
i don't know ectoplasmic sort of
surface where if you break the rules
nobody knows what to do with you you
know rather like tommy robinson for a
long time kept doing whatever he wanted
to do and every time they arrested him
it didn't really stop him doing what he
wanted to do and he kept doing it and i
mean he's now disappeared up his own ass
i think because he's just a little bit
of an idiot but at the end of the day um
boris will not be
told
to conform and because he doesn't do
what he's meant to they don't understand
what to do with them you know they all
said well any decent person would have
resigned by now well guess what he's not
going to resign
so you might as well forget about that
so maybe he's not a decent person who
cares doesn't really matter you know
these people who criticize him for being
you know immoral
you know
i hope they haven't got anything in
their lives which could be pointed to as
you know perhaps moralistically um you
know dodgy most people have you know
most journalists certainly have but
they're all holier than now so he's a
terrible individual he's a ghastly
person he's a liar you know he cheats on
his wife
i mean you know what's that got to do
with anything the point is is that he
will continue to do his job until such
time as he's literally stopped
physically from doing it but that's kind
of my question mike though do you not
think that it is a problem that someone
can behave as he has done and not be
removed and i think part of the reason i
would argue i argued on my recent sub
stack about this that
we have a dearth of high quality
candidates to replace them
the conservative party i i don't know
who who would be what jeremy hunt who
was screaming down the phone shut it
down we need quarantine camps i know is
that who we want no absolutely not
like who are these people i think
the problem we've got i think is we've
got this dearth of of quality because
we've encouraged
this little political class to become
very much um sort of self-fulfilling if
you like you know so you can only really
become a politician now if you play this
game whereby you're somebody's special
advisor that you then get given a sort
of safe seat or maybe not a safe seat to
lose before you get given a safe seat to
win
and you know it's all about patting each
other on the back there's no real
ideology anymore i mean this is what i
suppose i should have said earlier when
we were looking at thatcher thatcher
believed in things you know she believed
in crushing the unions because she
thought they were too powerful she
believed in having a certain economic
kind of policy because she wanted to
give people genuinely the ability to
make more money i mean she created
the situation for my generation to make
money you know because before that
you were born into a sort of what i
would term
you know lower middle class household
you weren't really going anywhere you
probably weren't going to university my
sister ended up working in the city
because of the big bang and you know
stock markets opened up if you weren't
in the old days the son of a stockbroker
you couldn't get into that you know
in my day you could still get into
newspapers without a degree which i was
able to do
and you had the ability to make bucket
loads of money now i think social
mobility is is as bad as it's ever been
you know if you don't have rich parents
in this country you can't really do very
well you can't get a decent job you
can't probably get a decent education
because your parents can't afford to put
you through university and you're kind
of stuck where you are and i think the
political class now is so
far and away removed from ordinary
people
i don't think they even know what
ordinary people do i mean they all get
their
bills paid they get expenses they drive
around in cars that you know they don't
have to worry about paying for i think
it's just become such a soft world
you know that they are and no no it's
all about ambition it's all about what
job can i get rather than what do i want
to change about society i can't name
anything that kierstarma wants to change
about society i can't name one thing
that angela rainey wants to change about
society or boris johnson or rishi sunak
or you know i just can't think of anyone
who believes anything
it's it's so true and and it's not just
that it's just a complete lack of vision
as well like if you asked johnson where
do you want this country to be in four
years time i mean he'd probably hit you
with some platitudes oh yeah but he'll
go on about you know british pride and
the flag and we're the greatest country
in the world but it doesn't mean
anything
you know it really doesn't
and i think a lot of people in this
country don't really know
what britain stands for anymore
other than if it's boris johnson it's
just getting away with it
i think and that's a real problem
because people look at him and he's not
a serious individual no he's not serious
he doesn't command respect
in his own pocket
with his own voters let alone overseas
so what does that say about us as a
country yeah i mean i don't know that
that's true about what happens overseas
i think there is still a respect for the
prime minister of great britain
overseas no matter what i mean zelensky
has been quick ukrainians are massive
fans johnson i mean he's done a really
good thing and i mean at his best he is
that he is that guy
but like all kind of flawed
domestic politicians you know his his
kind of arena of excellence is overseas
aid it's overseas policy his foreign
policies what the american presidents
always do whenever they're getting
stupped domestically they start a war or
they you know invade somewhere or they
do something which makes it look like
they're kind of straddling the world
stage and he does that very well he got
lucky in this case but you know i mean
my dad used to say about people that the
first time you meet some people that's
the best you get and i think boris is a
bit like that the more you get to know
him the worse it is you know he's quite
impressive when he walks into a g7
meeting probably but by the end of it
you're kind of going really
is this the guy you know but he can look
and first impressions can be important
and i think first impressions he can he
can do the business but i just don't
think he stands for anything yeah and i
like i say i
i i am not a fan of boris johnson at all
but my bigger worry is there's no one
who's a credible threat to him on his
own side yeah most of him in my opinion
are equally useless yeah uh
and they also like the charisma that at
least he has he's quite
charismatic but he can be very funny
absolutely you know
sometimes intentionally
but on the other side
on the other side you don't have a
credible threat either and frankly
like i would really struggle to vote for
the tories at the next election
but the only thing that might make me
consider it is the quality of the
opposition yeah well kirstama in prime
minister's questions this week
absolutely open goal to rip boris
johnson to shreds and he missed it
just didn't do it you know didn't even i
said today
um if you'd kind of come down from mars
and landed in the commons during prime
minister's questions you wouldn't have
even known that boris johnson had been
the subject of a vote of no confidence
in his own party you know it took me in
blackford to bring it up he actually was
quite funny for the first time you know
i quite you know i
but trouble is i'm torn you see by being
a journalist and a broadcaster as well
as being a citizen because i kind of
quite like the chaos i quite like the
absolute disaster that is the government
and the way that the country is going
you know the petrol crisis
is is something that
we can really get behind get our teeth
into the nhs being completely hopeless
is something which kind of you know
works well for me
as a subject to talk about because we
get incredible stories from people you
know if everything was really going well
i don't think we'd be doing quite as
well as we are you know yeah there's a
part of that of me which kind of what is
wedded today i hear you but i also think
as you know speaking to ordinary people
every day
this this is hurting people oh sure
i've got two teenage sons right i have
no idea what they're going to end up
doing with their lives and it's going to
be very difficult for them i think to
you know um
chart a course through their education
and then into employment you know
because even if they knew for sure what
they wanted to do it's a very uncertain
world we live in now it's a very unusual
place for anyone i mean i don't remember
that much about my 20s but um
you know i kind of just did what i
wanted to do and i kind of did all right
i think it's a lot harder now for
example you know um and they'll be
reasonably well well advantaged because
you know
their parents have got some money if
you're a kid growing up in a place where
there's nothing in the north of england
or even in the south people forget that
you know this leveling up stuff is not
just about the north of england i mean
there's plenty of parts of britain in
the south of the country which are in
really bad ways you know and if you're
growing up in a poor community somewhere
in dorset
you know you've got no chance of getting
anywhere doing anything you know you're
too far from london to get a job you
can't probably live in london because
you can't afford it your parents can't
give you any money because they don't
have any and what are you gonna do you
know yeah it's
and what i'm really worried about mike
is you're looking at things like
inflation the cost of living crisis
and you think things are going to get
quite ugly aren't they potentially
because if people are working and they
can't meet their basic needs
and they're working
a full-time job that's a recipe for
disaster it really is it really is and i
mean we're being taxed
far too much you know more than we've
ever been taxed in my lifetime um
by a conservative government well you've
got to tax people if you're going to
give everyone loads of money well that's
what we're told but now we're told that
they're going to give us some back
but how they're going to do that i don't
know you know this windfall tax
supposedly is being used to give
everybody um you know council tax rebate
but that's not really going to help many
people i mean i've seen 150 pounds as
council tax rebate for my council tax
and i'm not saying i need the money
that's a month and a half's council tax
out of a year
you know what what the hell is the point
of that and you know they need to make
things cheaper i don't know how they do
that
you know we seem to be stuck in the
spiral of just everything's going up i
mean today we were having calls from
people about the most expensive petrol
in britain and it turns out that it's
somewhere in there was between at one
point it was um
somewhere on the m6 we ended up with
somewhere in chelsea two pound 20. wow
for a liter of petrol
and he's just going that's and it's
going up literally by the day
for no reason suddenly it's jumped 5p
from yesterday and you go well why
how is that possible people say oh well
you know it's market forces it's not
market forces it's it's profiteering
surely
why do you think that might why do you
think it's not market for because i
don't believe that the cost of petrol
and diesel and oil
at wholesale level has changed in fact
it's gone down and yet the prices at the
pubs are going up
somebody put this to me how about this
and i haven't investigated it so i don't
i can't say that it's true
but there's one major chain of service
stations in this country which appears
to be owned
by a university pension fund
now whenever you're looking for
profiteering you look at the the not so
much the actual market forces but you
look at like the futures markets you
look at commodities i mean for example
all the prices that are going up because
of the wheat problem that's all being
driven by commodity markets it's all
been driven by speculators in new york
hong kong singapore london who are
betting on the price of wheat in the
future that's costing you and i you know
two quid on a loaf of bread
and i think that's the problem i don't
know i can't sound like a communist here
but you know some of these market forces
are market forces which are manufactured
in my view capitalist sort of market
forces in very strange and convoluted
you know a bit like the um
you know the mortgage fallout from 2008
when the banks were all failing it was
because of these ridiculous packages of
investments that were being put together
by these rocket scientists in wall
street who were packaging up you know
risk and saying i'll take your mortgage
and i'll sell it to him
but i'll also package it up with 500
other mortgages because the price of
property is always going to go up as
long as it happens we'll make money and
then the profit started to go because
the price of property went down and they
went oh [ __ ]
suddenly we haven't got any money and
suddenly the banks are all collapsing
and all you know there's a lot going on
which i think we don't know about yeah
and you so you host your show and people
call in what's the thing that the
ordinary bloke or woman on the street
talks about the things they care about
the most are
the green the net zero crap which nobody
wants nobody wants to buy into that even
especially now more than ever the
migrants who come illegally and the cost
of living those are the three things and
those are the three most important
issues in britain today
regardless of what you know politicians
will say and the first and the third are
totally quite
the well they're not correlated they're
related directly of course they are
because if it wasn't for this kind of
net zero obsession
we would not be you know paying so much
money for the energy that we've got i've
always said to people look if you want
me you want to buy an electric car then
sell me a cheap electric car if you want
to convince me not to drive a big gas
guzzling 4x4 sell me the same car
for less money if it's electric but
instead of that you buy the electric
version of my car it costs twice as much
why would you bother and it's got half
the range yeah half the range and also i
was watching there's a great video which
is out on twitter today
uh from ford in america and the ceo of
ford is a woman is out like you know
installing the virtues of this new
electric car and somebody says
what's currently charging your charge
points
and she's like oh i think we're getting
it from the local um
lansing energy company they go to the
lansing energy company and they say
where's your energy coming from they're
like it's 98 coal
and you go so you're charging electric
cars with electricity generated by coal
that doesn't really seem quite like the
green dream does it
you know and as much as we want
electricity uh to be clean i don't have
a problem with that
but it's not practical it doesn't work
and you know most ordinary people can't
afford a bloody tesla
you know it's too expensive and if you
if you did have one you can't charge it
and people go don't worry you charge it
the night before
well fine if you've got something you
can charge it with or two but if you're
parked in a street where there's a lot
of flats in the middle of london where
are you gonna charge it exactly
it's not happening
and the so let's touch on the the
migrant crisis and
is that really a very big issue for most
people yeah because again it's not
simply about people arriving on beaches
and walking into britain without any
reason to do so it's about pressure on
the nhs it's about pressure on the
economy it's about what they're doing
here nobody really knows it's about the
millions it's 5 million pounds a day
this is costing this government to house
them all in in in hotels
you know i'm not going to be one of
those people that says you know they're
all potentially criminals or terrorists
i'm not saying that but they shouldn't
be here we shouldn't be paying them to
be here and we shouldn't be charging the
taxpayer you know the equivalent of 30
million on quid a week
to help them to come so
mike what how is it that a government
that essentially was elected for one
reason which is a promise to deliver
brexit
right yeah
which was promised to people as a way of
controlling immigration because we take
back control over control of our borders
right where's the [ __ ] control there
is no
there is why not why is that government
not doing that because because look
there's a i don't understand the logic
here because if you say this is what
people care about and i'm sure that all
those people voted for the tories at the
last election then surely electorally
it must be an open goal for the tories
to fix that problem you would think so
why are they doing it because again i
think it's something that they
physically don't know what to do
to stop it you know a bit like they
don't know how to stop boris johnson
from breaking the rules and getting away
with it
they physically don't know how to stop
them i mean i've actually said there's a
very simple way to do it and it would be
simple um and you might laugh at this
but i would literally go to france with
one of those rambo knives every time you
see a dinghy you just stick the knife in
it the diggy can't go in the water it's
that simple and they you know then
they're not coming right
people look at me like you're looking at
me
i'm going it can't be that well what i'm
thinking inside of my head it may
no if you physically can't get in a boat
you're not coming i've just got this
image of you in a wetsuit just going
around doing that to dingies seriously
if you can't get in the dinghy you're
not coming i've got like a movie image
on my head mike like just comes out of
the water with like camera
yeah i mean they've got this i mean
we're talking that kind of level of
madness yeah because everybody knows who
these people are everybody knows where
they're coming from everyone knows how
they're getting here surely you just
stop them from doing that
but now we're sending them all to rwanda
sorry mate yeah yeah now i'm not being
sent to rwanda you have to unfortunately
if you the first flight to rwanda i want
to be on that so we can do a show from
rwanda from kigali um but it now looks
like they're saying oh well you know the
first flight might be difficult because
there's lawyers in the way why don't we
just send them back to france mate
that's why i don't understand well
because we're frightened of doing that
you know whenever you say turn the boats
back people go people might die not that
many people die we've had 10 000 people
have come already this year i don't
think anybody's died so far this year
it's pretty i mean i go down south coast
pretty much every weekend it's like a
mill pond the serpentine is busier and
you know more rough than the channel at
most of the times of the year and you
know there's no reason why
um we owe these people anything you know
when we get told by the lefties all
they're fleeing you know war and trauma
and disaster well they look pretty happy
when they get here they've all got
phones that they were able to throw into
the river i mean i wouldn't throw my
phone away i paid a lot of money for it
but they apparently don't seem to care
about that
my belief is that many of them are
coming here as part of a criminal
enterprise because they're being paid to
do so by human traffickers who want them
to come here not because they're going
to you know commit horrible awful
heinous crimes but they'll work in the
black economy you know whether whether
they're
washing cars whether they're running
brothels whether they're running you
know money laundering schemes i don't
know but it seems to me that that's the
aim they're not coming here to become
doctors you know they're not coming here
to join the police force they're not
coming here because they like the look
of highbury you know they're coming here
to do a job of work and i think it's for
the human traffickers who run criminal
gangs it's more lucrative now to smuggle
people into smuggling cocaine and that's
what they're doing
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com forward slash
triggered that's easydns.com
forward slash triggered use our promo
code which is also triggered and get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter axis of easy which
tells you everything you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
mike why don't why can't we have honest
conversations about this why is it that
i turn on my tv
and
we're not going to have an honest
conversation about this on the bbc or
channel four
because people
are
either squeamish or deluded or
completely and utterly kind of wedded to
this idea of a global world that
literally doesn't have any borders and
if you live in a place where
you know ethnic minorities have taken
over the the part of the world that you
know that didn't used to be like that
you're going to feel pretty weird about
that you're not going to be in favor of
it you're not going to be happy about it
you know there are parts of london which
i drive through from time to time um and
you can see that it's full of people
from eritrea or full of people from
ethiopia now i've got no problem with
that but i don't live there but if
you're some white guy who lived there
for 40 50 years and you look around and
you see everything's changed you go
there's something a bit bit odd about
this this isn't this is not what i
recognize as my place i'm as much in
favor of multicultural cities as anybody
but i think the problem is is that one
because it's out of control
you don't know
what's going on people feel helpless i
mean i was listening to nick ferrari the
other day and he said well maybe we
should just let them come is that quite
a small number of people it's not really
going to have an impact on most of the
country are you going sorry
what are you talking about you know if
you're talking about 30 000 people a
year
that's a small town in britain every
single year you know
um
and that's going to have an impact on
everything
but this is the thing the people on the
left who refuse to talk about this don't
understand that actually
that has an impact like you said before
on public services yeah on schools on
the nhs absolutely i mean it so happens
that most of the people who come on the
boats
have brown skin that's not really the
issue there's plenty of albanians coming
as well
there was a load of albanians that came
the other week and unfortunately whether
you like it or not a lot of people who
come from albania are hooked into the
drugs culture into the criminal culture
there's a lot of gangs in albania you
know they're not coming here legally
because they don't want to come legally
they want to come illegally so they're
not traceable you know people
unfortunately these do-gooders have this
view that everybody's got goodness in
their heart sorry to disappoint you
everybody hasn't got goodness in their
heart you know and some people are
coming here because they want to make
money they don't want to pay tax and
they want to make use of whatever it is
that's here that they want that they
can't get at home you know even in a
place like poland the average salary is
50 of what it is here you know of course
they want to come and work here and want
to live here but we can't just keep
saying that's not a problem
you know and most people in this country
give a [ __ ] about that well i no i agree
with you and the thing is as well is
that we are now quite plugged into that
immigrant labor to the extent that for
example we had james cavarinian here who
runs a restaurant in west london and he
made the point that whether it was
brexit or whether it's coveted and
whatever we've got to a position
actually we're very short on staff in
certain like airports are getting
flights cancelled restaurants are really
struggling to hire staff uh you know
farms etc because we've come to rely on
people and now the arguments become we
need these people to do the jobs that we
don't want to do
how much juice do you think there is i
think there's truth to that but i think
you've got to think about the reason
the second part of that sentence which
is the jobs that we don't want to do the
problem in this country is that people
are paid not to work and there's an
awful lot more people on benefits than
it should be on benefits and for a lot
of people it makes no sense to go to
work because they're better off if
you're on a minimum wage scenario and
you've got two or three kids you're
better off not working because you get
to have more money and you get to have
more
liquidity and more cash to spend if you
just stay on benefits because you get
your housing benefit you get your
council tax paid you know you get
whatever it is that tops up
even small amounts of money that you
might make if you do a bit of part-time
work but there's no reason for you to
become a waiter in james q arena's
restaurant because you're better off not
doing it and it's also quite hard work
so i think we've got a class of people
in this country who don't want to work
but it's not really their fault it's the
government's fault for paying them not
to
and you know in america for example and
i know this from living there
you get six months unemployment and if
after six months you haven't found a job
you don't get any more money
and i think that's a great system
because if you can work you should
and a lot of people in america work
because they want the health care that
goes with it
you know you need to incentivize people
to work and i'm not going to buy this
[ __ ] that you know oh all the people
have gone back because of brexit i mean
some of them have
five million i think stayed so it's not
true to say they all left because they
didn't like britain being an
isolationist country but in the end
um
they were working for less money than
british people were willing to work for
and you have to up the wages the whole
point of brexit was to pay people better
to make more money
and if and if if that was to happen
i think more people would be working for
james and other people you know mike
moving on now we talked about the past
of journalism what do you think is going
to be the future of journalism we've
just you know talked tv you should
obviously be taught radio now it's talk
tv so what do you think is going to be
the future with the media landscape well
i think as we move forward there will
become there will be more kind of
fragmentation of it and more people will
watch less of one thing
so they will be given a bigger sort of
menu of what it is that they want to see
you know at the moment there is still a
large amount of dominance in terms of
the bbc and itv
um less so channel 4 less so channel 5.
but what i have seen recently is a move
towards more
opinionated programming so skye have now
got an in you know a sort of an interest
in putting out
personality-led
programs although their personalities
aren't much to write home about
unfortunately and you've got sophie
ridge and sort of you know beth rigby
and uh what's his name trevor phillips
much of a muchness you know trevor's
great trevor is a good fan he's a good
guy but you know are people gonna watch
him for him they still don't quite know
how to do it you know i prefer the
american model where people are much
more opinionated there's a lot of
journalists in this country who still
can't quite get their heads around that
you know there's nothing wrong with
being opinionated you know as long as
you're willing to take the flak and
you're willing to listen to people who
might disagree with you i think people
are much more
you know savvy now about that and they'd
rather watch somebody with a decent
opinion
than somebody who just tells you that
you know there's an earthquake in
krakatoa you know here's a news program
about it and you know here's the rest of
the news i think people are
liable to be much more kind of specific
about what they like
and it won't just be on television it
will be on youtube it will be on you
know different platforms podcasting is
is obviously you know still a very
popular thing um
so i think the major powers like the bbc
and itv will become less powerful
over time and i mean the bbc is already
wrestling with itself they don't even
really know where they are anymore you
know they tried to hire matthew stadlin
which was probably the stupidest idea
anybody ever had
and then they decided not to and you
kind of go what was that all about well
didn't you know that he was a massive uh
you know labour right did you not know
that he'd been
basically having a nervous breakdown on
twitter for the best part of the last
two years i mean where have you been and
at least have the carriage you can
pictures and hire him and we can all
have a good laugh you know i don't even
know what radio 5 live is about anyway i
haven't listened to it for so long i
don't even know what they do
you know am i are you
when i say you i mean tv people are you
uh i've never been described as tv
people before but listen you are now you
are now uh
are you can are you do you consider us a
threat are you worried about youtube and
podcast and all of that coming i don't
consider anybody a threat but you know
it might just be me no no i think the
more the merrier i think the better the
the landscape is for the more
different opinions and and you know i
respect you guys what you do i think
what you do is great um
i don't listen to everything that you do
because nobody's got the time
but i know i think i think absolutely
the more diverse opinion out there the
better you know and i you know i can't
imagine anything worse than than people
just agreeing with me i don't want
anyone to really agree with me i have
much better time when people don't agree
but what i would like to see
is a bit more tolerance of different
opinions you know all round whereby you
know i know personally people who
have never been asked to appear on the
bbc because they consider to be you know
toxic
or you know you couldn't possibly put
them on i mean i don't even watch
question time anymore question time used
to be
thursday night fodder for me no matter
what same i would always watch it i
can't remember the last time i watched
it because it's so dull you know
panorama now is kind of boring all of
the old style stuff has gone and i think
you guys and and and we maybe to to a
lesser extent can just be more
innovative and we can do things i mean
i've said to my bosses i would love to
do like some documentaries i'd love to
do
some in-depth you know
investigations of you know stuff that
nobody else is really doing because at
the moment it's kind of if it's not on
the bbc or dispatches on channel 4
there's not really much of that going on
and it's hard to do because you need
resources you need a team of people you
need to be able to get things right like
i said you know this business of um
whether or not pension funds are driving
up the price of fuel that's a great
story but you have to really dig into it
for a while and it you know it takes a
bit of time costs a bit of money
um
and i think that the one thing i would
say i probably do regret is the sort of
upsurge of what i would regard as kind
of shills dodgy uh types on youtube
people who sell
themselves to people as if they're
telling them some kind of conspiracy
theory and we get a lot of this now you
know it's a lot more frequent than it
used to be you know like i've had the
you know the the russian bots after me
you know for you know being too
pro-ukraine i've had uh you know the
anti-vaxx crowd saying to me that we
should be covering you know people who
are injured by vaccines you know all of
which we've you know we've covered all
of these things but you get sort of
labeled as you know i'm in the pay of
bill gates
and it's like you know guys and i know
they're probably not as big of a deal as
as they make out but there's a lot more
of them there were
and i think they get encouraged to be
the way they are by certain unscrupulous
people yeah who make money out of it you
know
and i think that would be nice if they
would disappear but equally it's not for
me to say who should be
disappearing you know they they have to
stand on their own
merits but um i'd like people to be
slightly more i suppose
thoughtful about who they believe and
who they don't believe you know mike do
not worry do you not worry in this
fragmented media landscape that that's
just going to mean we're all going to be
in our own little silos and we're going
to talk to each other less and we're
going to share ideas less as a result
because if you want right of center
content you're going to go to this
broadcast so if you want left wing
content you're going to go to this if
you want kind of a more libertarian
content you're going to go over here
and really you the ideas aren't going to
cross-pollinate well there's a danger of
that but then that's up to us isn't it i
mean it's up to us to make sure that
that doesn't happen by making sure that
we encourage others who maybe we don't
believe like like you were saying
constantin earlier you know you get
guests on here who you don't necessarily
think would fit into your world or in
your particular frame of reference and
then the people that like you will have
a chance to look at that you know and i
think i think it's up to us all
to do that you know i mean there are
certain things that i
have said um like i will not have
you know these eco nutters you know on
the shows that i do just because i don't
think they deserve to get the oxygen
publicity but but people know they exist
and there are plenty of people who
um argue with me about it on twitter um
i think it's down to us not to become
too insular and to make sure that you
know we continue to bring things to be i
mean i genuinely have been surprised at
how sometimes i'll say something
and people go i didn't know that you
know i had no idea that that was the
case and you know i think it's about
education it's about information
certainly not about misinformation it's
not about
um
censoring things i think the more people
know the better because i think i trust
people to make sensible choices the the
one worry that i have mike is that and
we are constantly battling against this
is that you do see some channels that
are captured by their own audience
you know and like bbc again
yeah exactly i don't even know that's
true about the bbc i think a lot of what
their audience used to be is actually
switching off and they're losing
massively in terms of license players
yeah i'm sure that's true actually
they're not captured by their audience
what they are is they're captured by a
small group of elite people at the top
elite in the united comments at the top
well there's an awful lot of them i mean
i'm always constantly amazed at the
numbers of people who appear on the bbc
news shows and you go
who's that science editor he's like
never seen him before they come here
washington correspondent you know
incredible but so you mean like smaller
things yeah so you know that they're
doing very well and they become in a
sense captured by their own audience
they're never going to give anything to
their audience which contradicts their
worldview because they don't want to
antagonize alienate them and therefore
make lessons i mean i think that's right
and i mean i've come up against that as
i say in the last couple of years
because
part of our audience for a while because
during the lockdown we were very
anti-lockdown we were very anti sort of
you know being told what to do by the
government people then expected us to be
sort of in some ways um anti-covered and
they expected us to come out and say
that kobe was a hoax and you know people
shouldn't get vaccinated and we didn't
do that they didn't like it but i think
you've got to stay true to what it is
you believe you know you have to take
the path
which sometimes means you're going to be
you can be losing people i mean i lost
something like 2 000 followers one
weekend on twitter because i made a joke
about you know not a joke exactly but
somebody went don't you think it's
important to do vaccine damage you know
i went not really literally a throwaway
line you know and they all went that's a
disgrace you know he's in the pay of
bill gates he's
and i'm like well you know the fact is
we've vaccinated 40 million people and
400 people have had a problem and yes
there are issues with that but you've
got to be very careful how you do it and
we have actually covered it but you know
what i won't say
is that this is a you know deliberate
ploy to somehow you know microchip
people so that we can be told what to do
a week on saturday you know when you go
out it's not true you don't need a
microchip for that mate we've got the
police to come up with that right but
that's what i mean you know i think you
can be sensible
and you can have your views and you have
to not be scared of losing your audience
i think there are some broadcasters i'm
not going to name any who kind of
i would say exploit their audience by
continuing a narrative which they know
isn't true
and to talk about things like you know
the wef
and bill gates and to talk about this is
the biggest you know grab of
personal um data that anybody's ever
seen what do they want to do with it you
know and we should all be vigilant about
it you know of course but you know don't
frighten people i think a lot of people
out there are scared to death because
they genuinely believe that you know
klaus schwab's coming for them
you know he's not
is he
yes
that's the thing you know and i just i
just think it's really dangerous that
you know you know let's not lose
um
the fact that you know logic is
generally speaking the best place to be
spoken like a true bill gates chill
there mike of course um listen good to
have you back on the show always a
pleasure chatting with you uh we're
going to do a couple of questions for
our supporters only after the interview
but before we do that we've got our
final question as always which is what's
the one thing that we're not talking
about as a society that you think we
should be
now that's interesting um because it's
hardly anything we don't talk about
that you can find where nobody's doing
anything
i think one of the things that we don't
really say often enough
is that most people don't give a [ __ ]
about trans
no one most people i know
who are sensible ordinary citizens of
this world
you know not only do they not know
anybody who's trans but actually they
don't care
about what they think and that's not for
me to say that i'm therefore going to
try and get your window smashed in by
trans activists but you know
we had a survey the other day in which
it said you know people think there's a
lot more trans people in britain than
there really are a lot more minorities
because they get fed this constant diet
of kind of you know
the gay movements the you know the queer
movements the the curious move whatever
the [ __ ] they are you know they're all
you know having a great impact on our
world they're really not you know
i think the truth is that the trans
community is something like .005
of the actual population
and it doesn't really you know all of
this crap
about jk rowling about you know
whether or not trans people can be
played by people who aren't trans in
movies you know
it's really nobody cares and people
don't talk about that i don't think
thank you so much if people want to find
you online where is the best place to do
that well twitter is where i'm mostly
which is ir omg the independent republic
of mike graham some people mistakenly
think it's iron mike which they kill me
which have never been killed and they
have a go at me again what sort of
conceited [ __ ] calls himself iron
mike it's not a name i don't know the
ufc fighter calls himself iron man well
there was iron mike tyson yeah and i
might i'm mike chandler i think there's
probably a few of them but i'm certainly
not one of them um
i'm on facebook as well but yeah better
or worse and just find me on talk tv
which is why i'm pretty much all the
time perfect thank you very much mike
been a pleasure as always and thank you
for watching and listening we will see
you with another brilliant episode like
this one uh in a few days uh thanks for
watching i'll see you soon
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
they said i'm a great believer in owning
nothing you know rent everything because
that way nobody can come after you